[Music]
hi and welcome to episode number 97 of
the weekly Google cloud platform podcast
I am Francis Campo and I'm here with my
colleague Mark Mandel hey Mark how are
doing I am very well how are you doing
today
pretty happy back from Chicago you're
back from your favorite conference of
all time strangely yes yes and we're in
the same place at the same time yeah I
don't see new ranch loop t-shirt I was
wearing yesterday okay that's why good
not be using the same t-shirt days yeah
anyway so today we're going to have
something really special because two
managers from the firebase team are here
to talk about something that was
announced yesterday yeah we're pretty
quick cloud firestore which is an
amazing thing it's basically if you love
firebase real-time database it is
basically something similar but even
more powerful yeah so if you have huge
scaling needs or you need to do really
cool filtering stuff like that
CalFire stories for you yeah if you want
that real time database goodness as well
yeah it's pretty awesome it is really
really cool and we're gonna have both
Dan McGrath and Alexi Fidel they're
going to tell us all about it and after
that we'll have our question of the week
which is not about cloud firestore but
about cloud datastore yeah we're gonna
have a quick chat about I've got stuff
in datastore but I'd really like to be
able to export it maybe so I can use it
locally or in other things how do I do
that yeah backup stuff like that yeah
maybe you can you want to export it into
a van or bigquery or whatever many ways
of doing it and we have something news
that we're going to discuss on that but
before all of this we have our cool
things of the week and the first one is
something that I think is it was really
cool that we announcement like oh by the
way we're announcing per second billing
on Google platform yeah that was like
okay we've done that good yeah I find
it's a very nice blog post and go with
it and there's no what you think I think
it's very well written yes I agree yeah
I like it I like it a lot actually it's
kind of cool that the one thing I like
about it is
it does talk about sort of the
difference between per minute and per
second billing yeah going from per hour
to per minute the amount of money that
you're gonna save is is quite large or
is going per minute to per second yeah
it is exact with one you can buy coffee
with the other one you can buy a coffee
machine yes I love that so yeah it was
really cool previously the only thing
that were built per second were actually
persistent disks and think there's also
the use discounts on GPUs but now it is
basically all of the things so you have
compute engine container engine called
data prog up engine flexible and the
cool thing is that this was announced as
something that you know like it's going
to be implemented but not really it was
September 26 was like oh by the way this
is effective now yeah you're already
saving money you don't need to do
anything it's just there which is cool
let's go to the second to cool things of
the week actually two new languages are
general availability on App Engine so
yeah so we have PHP 7.1 and I'm not at
PHP expert by any way but one of the
things that is cool is that
it is it has now support for site driver
logging and network reporting which is
really important because if you have an
application running on production being
able to see what is going on and when it
fails understand how it failed it is
really important insect rubber helps you
with that yep and then we also have Java
8 yes sir Java 8 very simple and
obviously something people wanted for a
very long time lambdas yeah but now that
means like if you want to use Java 8
basically just add Java 8 line to your
App Engine - web.xml file redeploy your
application and you're pretty much good
to go it was pretty cool during the beta
release they continued to enhance the
performance of the runtime such that so
many customers were able to see like
benefits going all the way through on
that platform but now you can use to
have an eight yeah and something that is
mentioned quite quick but it I think is
really really important is the fact that
doing with Java 7 there was a lot of
limitations among other things on
security on the class loader and that
limited the number of classes that you
could load so there was a why
list of classes of Java classes that
were supported that has been removed and
the same thing for the usual threat
execution well yeah I wonder how unusual
that was I mean there's a story there
but yeah those two things have been
completely removed so App Engine with
Java eight is basically just Java 8 on
App Engine
yes special duty 9 fully abound G RPC
connections you get all sorts of cool
stuff yeah very very cool very excited
about that really awesome
so of course one of my favorite topics
kubernetes kubernetes 1.8 is now been
released this time it's more it looks
like spotlight Security workload support
so some new features in our back I'm
pretty excited cron jobs finally have
come out of alpha and now beta that
makes me super happy it is good that it
makes you happy but it feels like
something so obvious and simple but I
mean if you need it it's useful like
it's a thing that you need to do across
the cluster machine once right so that's
I means now beta that's great so there's
there's a lot of work there being done
for actual like data storage things like
that if you want to do like key value
stores or some kind of storage engine
and stuff like that that's the stuff
that's really been solidified so yeah
another great release from the
kubernetes team rolling that out just
really kind of you know doesn't have to
be beacon slushee
yeah not another good thing and
congratulations to the kubernetes
community cuz like the yeah pace at
which they reach new features is amazing
so congratulations to them now one thing
that is cool if you run on gke and you
run on us there is some new stuff on us
the one thing I will mention will link
to the blog post is a bunch of stuff but
now if you go into the cloud console we
have a bunch more of like doohickeys
that you can basically look at so
there's a lot more information that you
can see about what's running inside
containers enable you can basically
start doing development tasks inside the
UI there's some fruit integration with
track driver and cloud shell you have a
look in the blog post but there's some
there's some pretty sweet stuff in there
cool
and for the last cool thing of the week
that we're gonna mention really quick it
is the fact that we're announcing cloud
IOT core public beta and we will have an
episode on cloud IRT so I will not get
too much into detail but basically if
you are managing fleet of devices IOT
devices and you need to manage them
manage the certificates make sure that
the connection is safe and all of this
things and that you're able to connect
with all of them and gather metrics from
them
IOT core is exactly for this use case
and check it out it is now public beta
so it's definitely the moment to go play
with it and let us know what you think
IOT all the things I ot all the course
yeah things yeah yes cool sweet so why
don't we go have a chat with Dan and
Alex and talk all about cloud fast or
sounds good little air so I am very
excited to welcome two product managers
from firebase both of them working in
the cloud firestore team Dan McGrath and
Alex loofah tell how are you both doing
excellent good morning hey morning doing
well good bright so we're gonna be
talking about the latest product that
was launched yesterday for firebase
which is a cloud firestore but before we
get into all of the cool details about
this new product well then you tell us a
little bit about yourselves what you do
at Google let's how were you then okay
so I'm a product manager on the cloud
via stellar team also working on cloud
datastore and before that I was on
Google Drive
so I'm a p.m. on the cloud firestore
team as well I also work on the firebase
real-time database and prior to joining
firebase actually ran and sold a company
that was powered by firebase products
which I'll probably touch a little bit
on cool alright so we're here to talk
about five store clearly firebase didn't
have enough cool things so we're just
gonna add one more extra cool thing who
wants to tell us like an overview level
like what is cloud five store so cloud
power store is a fully managed no sequel
database it comes as the second database
offering in the firebase portfolio so
users will now have two databases that
they can choose from the real time
database about firestorm so you
mentioned is that a number a tional
database which makes me think about
BigTable but I'm also assuming that it
is it has the all the goodness from the
real time database so it's still like
that real time the nature of it right so
stepping back a little bit caught fire
store addresses many of the limitations
of the real time database
the real time database has long been the
flagship product of firebase it was
among its first offering of products
and it solved many many hard problems
that they did bad developers have one it
makes it very easy to imagine scale your
back end and it powers allows developers
to power real time features which are
without without proper tooling very
difficult to build and it also allows
for to build offline ready apps the
problems with the real time database is
that as we scaled and the real time
database has really been is like is a
very successful product with hundreds of
thousands of developers using it but as
the database scaled and as we've started
having more usage usage patterns evolved
and what we saw is people using the
database for like across all their ad
needs not just the real-time bits and as
they are doing so they really had two
different types of limits the first is
around data structuring and querying and
the other is around scalability what
happens with the real-time database is
that if you want to build very
sophisticated perhaps and access your
data in very sophisticated ways you
sometimes have to structure it in kind
of convoluted ways and the other thing
is beyond or certain limit it scales
very well but beyond a certain limit you
need to start creating shards and those
are the problems kind of the core
problems that caught fire store solves
cool so could you tell us it'll be more
about where those limits are more or
less or audience can have an idea of
whether they should be using the real
time database or cloud verify store the
scalability limit of the real time
database is most often expressed as the
number of concurrent users that you can
have and those are approximately a
hundred thousand it's not really we put
this as a hard limit you may actually
hit some scalability issues before that
but most of the time this is where you
can reach a hundred thousand concurrent
users that is a lot that is yeah that is
yeah that's a big party
let's talk a little bit more about what
people were doing with the real time
database and how that motivated this
cloud firestore story you mentioned that
the way you were modeling data before
was sometimes awkward could you talk a
little bit more about that and how cloud
fire is different right um so first I'd
like to start with some of the things
that are similar yeah good idea
so first like the real time database
cloud forest or features rich client
SDKs
that allow you to build directly from
web iOS and Android and that's really a
big deal because it allows you to access
your data directly from your clients and
it basically allows you to not have to
build a proxy layer to do all the access
control the data validation and the
delivery of your data to your app so it
saves you a lot of time this is made
possible in the backend by a set of
security rules that developers can
define that basically allow you to
define who and how your data can be
accessed so along the way this model of
cleaners decays with rules also makes it
much easier to build more secure apps
the second thing that is similar with
the real-time database is that cloud
fire store allows you to fetch your data
in real time now this is actually a very
very big deal on the surface you may
think that it's great because it allows
you to build real time functionality
like typically you want to build a
collaborative whiteboard or you want to
build a messaging app and having a real
time database for that is really cool
it's it's well that's true the
advantages of having a real time
database extend way beyond that and
particularly things that he allows you
to do is to have just build much more
reactive apps the other thing is
nowadays you very often you need to sync
your data across potentially multiple
devices and you get that out of the box
with the real time database does this
also work say offline and online and a
real time database had that as an option
as well right so actually that is one of
the features that I think our group of
developers testing the firestore so far
has been most excited about because it's
something that's very complicated to
build as a developer because you need to
build all the the sync logic the
conflict resolution logic and fire store
does this completely behind the scenes
it does this for Android for iOS and now
it does this for web as well which is
unique and wasn't available
database for those listening one of the
things that is really powerful with this
is there's there's really two things to
offline one is a kind of the vanilla a
use case which is I want to use my app
offline purely say I'm going the plane I
have no Wi-Fi I want to use my app for a
couple hours and then when I reconnect
all my data gets sick back but there's
another aspect which is just as
important is what we call latency
compensation and what that is is
basically we switch between offline and
online behind the scenes for you so that
we can compensate for Network flakiness
so say you're in the airport you're you
have poor Wi-Fi what typically happens
when the normal app is your app slows
down as your requests slow down with
cloud fire so what happens is that we
automatically serve you what's in the
cache or we cache your rights so that to
wait for your network to be to be back
to testing those changes so as a user
your app continues working beautifully
and that's a new feature no latency
compensation was available for the
real-time database okay but this isn't
but now it's available for web as well
cool so now he's available for web as
well with cloud fire store or with cloud
firestorm cool so just back to the data
model question yeah so cloud fire store
features a familiar collection and
document model and this model is
architected with it has a little bit of
a twist over typical collection
documents because it allows you to very
easily structure your data
hierarchically and the reason why this
is important is that it allows you to
tie related data together and as we've
seen this is like the most intuitive way
to store your data and what we've
learned with the real-time database is
that it is extremely important that the
intuitive design patterns are also the
right ones this has two effects once it
considerably accelerates the the
learning curve when you're starting to
use the product but even more
importantly it prevents you from having
to re or connect your data as your app
grows so it's something that we're very
excited about the second thing that
we're very excited about is that this
data model comes with very expressive
queries which is really new compared to
the real-time database which had a very
basic querying language and last but not
least this these queries are extremely
performance so we've actually
architected the database and our queries
in a way that all queries scale with the
results set now the data set so that
means is that if you're querying
fetching one result out of 100 or out of
a hundred million you'll get the same
performance nice that's really nice
so could you talk a little bit about the
query capabilities of both the real-time
database and firebase and cloud
firestore what kind of things can you do
so typically with the real-time database
you were limited to a filter on a single
property um with Claude firestore you
can filter on multiple properties you
can mix equality's and inequality
filters you can do offsets you can do
curser positions you can be quite a
quite a bit offensive things can you do
aggregations like if you want to use
this report or it's not really that kind
of tool no you cannot do aggregations no
you can do small aggregations on the
client side
now I'm taking into account the
scalability factor of returning results
set rather than data set sides latency
cool so you mentioned that when you're
doing filters you doing filters or on
properties among other things those
properties are is there a schema for the
people that don't know that much but
like there's no sequel so I'd say no but
is there somewhere a list of all the
properties so like you mentioned that's
really a schema list database so that
means every document can have its own
independent schema you can get a list of
fields back from each document and query
against them but it makes it really easy
to continually evolve your app as you
add new fields to it you don't need to
go back and alter tables and wait for
things to rebuild cool awesome all right
so this sounds super cool I'm gonna ask
the question as well like is there like
apart from the client-side is there ways
of interacting with that on like the
back end is there like a server
integration pot yeah absolutely we
actually have a set of severus TK as you
can use whether it's compute VMS or
kubernetes cluster or even thank you're
running locally on your machine so we've
got
Java Python nodejs and go serve
available cool so what are those server
is or back-end is the case useful for
what kind of use case have you seen
people using them for many different
ones two quick examples are integrating
with the existing system so you're
writing a new mobile app and you want
data updates to be reflected out into
your mobile app or website you can do
that via the server SDKs the other big
one is sort of like offline big batch
processing you want to update something
or add new data into it that's very easy
to do just spin up a compute V M and off
you go
and since server list is the new hotness
is there some sort of cloud function
type thing going on
sure so Claude firestore allows you to
integrate with cloud functions allowing
you to trigger code on writes and
deletes and edits all right cool so what
does the development experience look
like is this integrated in like the
usual firebase tooling like how do i if
i want to want to play with this thing
what do i what am i writing so first if
you want to play with this head to
firebase create a project and then
download so you can either use it from
the client SDKs iOS Android or web or
the server SDKs we were talking about
just download the SDKs load your config
and you're ready to go that's it that's
it pretty much yeah cool so easy one of
the things that I love about firebase
real-time database is that that that
dashboard but you can see the data but
you have time and you like if your
program changes something just like
changes colors and stuff but amazing
it's like for demos the best thing ever
- cloud firestore also support these
kind of things yes it does it is
something that we're also very excited
about I think when I first discovered
firebase like many years ago it was
actually my co-founder had discovered it
over the weekend and he showed me his
his laptop with that dashboard and
things changing in real time he had
created a whiteboard so we were in
collaboration he had created a
whiteboard he showed me how you could
move a square around the whiteboard
those coordinates would update in
real-time through the data viewer and we
were hooked it was fine it was it was
very funny and this was really core to
the experience of the firebase database
and so it really mattered to us that
we'd be able to provide a similar
experience with cloud firestore so we
did our best to - to do something as
cool and we look forward to having
feedback on what we did awesome um so
all of this sounds really great and you
talk about some comparisons between the
real-time database and then you caught
fire store does this mean like if I'm
sitting down and I've got a greenfield
project and I want to build a thing
should I use the real-time database
should I use cloud 5 store which one
should I use
so we're recommending for new apps to
use cloud fire store for developers who
are comfortable using a beta product
that's kind of the short answer the long
answer is you can use both products
together for most use cases cloud fire
store will be the best solution
for certain edge cases the real time
database might be more like make more
sense to use from a cost efficiency
perspective okay and the reason for this
is that so first of all the cost of
operating caught fire store and the
real-time databases are not the same
because one is a replicated database and
the other the other is not and so
typically with the real-time database
one thing that's something that is very
very efficient and cost efficient is to
update small bits of data very fast so
say you're building a collaborative
whiteboard and you want to move cursor
around and you sing that position and
you wanna sing about several times a
second this is something that the
real-time databases is well built for
because you're only charged for outgoing
bandwidth so even if you're doing many
many document writes it's still okay
yeah this model with cloud forest or it
doesn't make as much sense because first
of all we're replicating your data - for
for additional reliability and that type
of data doesn't make sense to be
replicated in that use case and and
cloud fires' or charges per operation so
you charge for every ride and delete
and it which is actually more intuitive
for most use cases but for this use case
for examples let's perform it so in this
type of scenario where we're telling
users is perfectly fine to use both
databases together the other thing is
both databases will live alongside in in
the firebase console and if you're using
the real time database today it is
totally fine too can you continue using
it or will be supporting and developing
both products going forward cool so when
you say that you can use both of them at
the same time that doesn't mean that the
data is replicating to both is that you
can know two different databases and you
should choose either one that's it you
can also use cloud functions to
replicate it or from one place to
another very easily so you mention real
quick something that is actually really
important for our audience which is data
replication you tell us a little bit
more about it yeah take that one Alex
mentioned it's a replicated database so
I'll tell you a little bit about how it
works under the covers it's what we call
a multi region replicated database and
that means whenever you write data we're
committing it not just to one or two
data centers where community to multiple
data centers across distinct
geographical regions so when you commit
data it actually is durable even in the
face of disasters doesn't mean that
those replicas also can take the reads
so if you audience is or your user bases
you distributed geographically they will
get the fastest yeah I think probably
the most important thing to note first
off is cloud feistel goes across
Google's internal network so that means
we're gonna inbound
your request from the closest point of
presence regardless of what country
you're in and use our fiber optics to
get you to the right data center to
serve data each data center that we
replicate to can serve data out of it
okay what about rights it's like
basically my question is is it like
master master active like is all of them
are active and can take the reads and
writes or do you always need to go to
one and the other one is just like we
replicate yeah so we are in an active
active configuration our system will
automatically route to where we think
the quick is
is going to be to start with though nice
do you get to configure how many
replicas you get or is that a fixed
number that is like the safe bet and
that's it so this is a fully managed
solution by Google that means Google
engineering takes care of everything for
you node count RAM allocation cluster
management is all handled by us so you
just need to think about how you use the
SDK he was mentioned before a mark was
mentioning before even to build
something from scratch which one should
it be using what if I'm already using
I'm already using real time database
right a fire buys firebase real time
database under what conditions would you
say that a clap fire store is something
that I should consider moving to so
there's a couple couple of I guess
scenarios where it makes sense one is if
you want to implement new functionality
that will require some complex query
then definitely give Clark power store a
try also I think the if you're really
interested in getting the benefits of
the multi-regional data sync then
definitely use cloud firestorm and again
you can use both together so what we've
been seeing in with our testers so far
especially those who are using the real
time database is they you can typically
just implement a new feature have some
of that data live in cloud fire store
and use cloud first or for that and it
also sounds like there's some web
capabilities that you wouldn't
necessarily be able to get inside real
time database yeah exactly so if you
want to if you want to power and not
flying ready web app then yes I
definitely use cloud firestorm so I'm
gonna ask the question because I do
stuff in gaming community stuff I would
like to see unity and C++ SDKs can we
have some please so this has been an
important request it's definitely
something that we would love to build we
don't have that are an immediate roadmap
but we care very much about that as well
can people have to leave for it they can
how if there's something missing so
we're going to have oh there is a
discussion group
you can join on Google Groups just look
for google cloud firestore discuss and
just tell us not just unity and c++ SDKs
that you might be looking for but
anything else that you think will really
flesh out the experience for you and
also we're going to be sharing both of
your to your handles so just saying cool
so we're kind of running out of time but
we always like to give the opportunity
to our guests to plug whatever you want
to add or is there anything that we left
unsaid that you think is important now
we're having our audience knows so one
thing I want to say get out there and
play with it you don't need a credit
card it's got a pretty awesome free tier
so you can use the SDKs today see what
it's like see how it's going to work for
your app without having to commit
anything nice that's a really really
good point that's a good point
yeah yeah just echoing with what Dan
says our our purpose is to make
developers efficient and happy so tell
us what you think of the product and how
we can improve it that sounds great if
there are there any like youtube videos
or blog posts or documentation in
particular places people should go to
learn about this stuff so there's a blog
post on the firebase blog definitely
read that there's actually two blog
posts one generally talking about the
product one more specifically going into
the differences with the real-time
database recommend reading both and then
the worship we ship the product with an
extensive set of documents so definitely
read up we don't they're cool we'll have
links to all of those from the show
notes fantastic well thank you to both
of you for joining us today on the
podcast to talk to us all about
firestore I think our listeners will
greatly appreciate it thank you thank
you thanks again to Dan and Alex for
spending such a delightful time with us
talk all about cloud firestore a really
really cool project I'm actually quite
excited to sit down and play with it and
see what I can build yeah I'm I'm also
very excited about that last mention of
oh by the way you can try it for free no
credit card yet that it makes it even
easier to try so I'm definitely going to
play a little bit with it and see how we
can help me build even better real time
stuffs yeah I know and I love the there
is a focus there I think more on the web
things yeah I definitely don't do that
much mobile programming so I think I'm
we're really kind of curious to see what
I can do on the website yeah really
really exciting awesome well why don't
we get stuck into our question of the
week I think this is kind of an
interesting one so we're talking about
data store this time data stores been
around for a really long time I've
wanted to always be able to do imports
and exports of data at a data store
right data store kind of proprietary we
we built it it's a thing it's quite
powerful but maybe I want to pull data
down for backups or I want to put it in
bigquery or something like that what
tools what things do I have available to
me there so this is an interesting one
because it's been changing over the time
and at some point so the store at the
beginning was just the way you store
data from App Engine it was available
only from App Engine and back then in
order to do backup or to export all of
the data what you had to do was to go
into some console and run MapReduce that
would actually run a MapReduce and you
would see the process and it would end
up storing all of this into some files
in a cloud storage bucket yep now the
thing is that there was no API for this
I don't say you had to go into it
manually now that that thing has been
replaced with something that we call the
managed export and import service sounds
fancy which it's fancy but it's beta
just so you know okay cool it's an
important thing to know and basically it
allows you to export any import data in
a very very simple way and it's very
exciting because this time rather than
being only part of the console it's more
like what we do nowadays right now it's
part of the API which you can also use
from g-cloud directly so super simple
and you end up being able to download
all the contents of your data store so
then you can upload it to other places
like let's say you want to upload it to
be query or whatever very simple today
from there you can also upload into data
store and I know that some people want
to do these kind of things for QA so you
have like a golden image or something
like that where you get you get that
file upload it to the data store and
then you start running from there this
is nice I'm actually having a look
through as well and I'm seeing that
there's a book so it looks like I am
permissions as well - yeah hook in here
so that you can dictate who or even what
services could then be able to import an
export
people shouldn't be able to just go oh
look I can import into production and
that's fine you'd have a lot of control
over this it looks actually really nice
the only warning that I would give to
anyone doing this is when you are doing
a backup you will be charged the price
of reading those entities so it's
something to keep in mind it is it is I
mean it makes sense because you're
actually reading those entities but keep
in mind that if you have a huge database
and you're taking backups every hour
that might be expensive so take that
into account and be careful with that
awesome well for instance before we wrap
up today what are you up to where you
going there just a funk there was a
first part of just a funk that I really
yes last week and next week I'll release
the second part of the same jazz of funk
which is a good review of some cool
package which I already forgot what it
did it was cool okay cool
no it was a URL shortener yeah it's a
cool thing I remember and yeah after
that so I will be going to London so on
the week of the 17th to the 20th it's
gonna be fun on the 17th I gonna be
speaking at the go meet up in London on
the 18th I'll be speaking in velocity
London on the 19th I'll be speaking at
Google cloud summit in Paris well what
about you so I'm not gonna refer about
two or three weeks which is wonderful
then I'm off to Australia dev fest
Melbourne I'll be there on the 21st of
October hanging out at unite Melbourne
I'll be speaking at game connector
asia-pacific and then I'll be at pax
Australia after that cool so yeah if you
see us around say hi yeah there's no it
was really cool to meet bunch of people
as we can Chicago that love the podcast
so thanks so much for all of you is to
say hi
also please review our podcast on iTunes
will be told to say that thing on iTunes
yeah stars 5 stars all the stars or more
yeah and also please get in touch with
us if you have questions we love
questions of the week yeah let us know
if you have interested on having some
specific topic that you'd like us to
cover like I don't know do you want us
to talk more about server layers or
kubernetes well more about kubernetes
other things
anymore but whatever topic you're
interested in and in order to do that
you can get in touch with us on Twitter
at GSP podcast on reddit / r / tcp
podcast or google+ plus a GC forecast on
MySpace we don't have maybe we should we
should have a myspace wait what else
we're on slack slack at the hatch
podcast channel on vitaly / in GCP -
slack and then finally we have a webpage
GP podcast calm and an email hello at
gzb podcast perfect sweet well Francis
thank you so much for joining me for yet
another episode thank you Mark and thank
you for listening and we'll see you all
next week
you